una de las principales ideas del libro
el capital en el siglo 21 es tomar el
rendimiento del capital después de
impuestos r es igual al rendimiento
rendimiento del capital
y compararlo con ce ce es igual al
crecimiento
económico
crecimiento económico con la condición
de que r sea mayor que se ya que si este
es el caso entonces tendrá asociado el
aumento de la desigualdad en el ingreso
una mayor cantidad del ingreso irá a los
dueños del capital y no tanto a la mano
de obra y ya que el capital tiende a
concentrarse en la parte superior y la
riqueza puede verse como capital y como
la riqueza tiende a concentrarse en la
parte superior esto hace que aumente
mucho más la desigualdad antes de que
veamos esto en detalle ya sea que
ustedes crean o no en esta causalidad
debemos comprender el concepto de
rendimiento del capital como esto puede
comparar el crecimiento económico y como
este puede generar rendimientos de
ingreso a los sueños del capital o
ingreso a la mano de obra para analizar
esto imaginemos una economía mucho muy
sencilla imaginemos que toda la economía
es una mina de oro este es el año 1
y todo el valor de la economía toda la
riqueza de esta el capital capital está
evaluado en mil
piezas
de oro
y aquí podríamos hablar de cómo está
valorado esto incluso podríamos hablar
del valor de mercado o si tiene un valor
más intrínseco pero para este ejemplo
nos quedaremos con un análisis más
simple para podernos dar idea de lo que
es el rendimiento del capital el
crecimiento económico y cómo se
relacionan entre sí quedamos que el
capital es de mil piezas de ahorros que
abre ver como p
digamos que en ese año el ingreso
nacional y recordemos que es una mina de
oro así que oro es lo único que produce
el ingreso nacional total es de 100
piezas de oro ahora esto se va a dividir
en el ingreso de la mano de obra ya que
necesitamos personas que trabajen en la
mina de oro y entre los dueños del
capital que son las personas que son
dueños de la tierra del equipo y todo lo
demás de la mina de oro
así pues 50 piezas de oro van para la
mano de obra y las otras 50 piezas de
oro van para los dueños del capital y
ahorita no vamos a entrar en detalle de
cuestiones de impuestos aún para no
complicar las cosas esto será después de
impuestos ahora podremos calcular el
rendimiento del capital r en el año 1 y
será si los dueños del capital reciben
50 piezas de oro y el capital que
emplearon fue de mil piezas de oro 50
entre 1000 va a ser 5%
ahora contemplemos esto en el contexto
del crecimiento económico
digamos que vamos del año 1 al año 2
este es el año 2 imaginemos que los
dueños del capital van a reinvertir todo
lo que recibieron como el rendimiento
del capital por lo que ahora la mina de
oro tendrá un capital capital en el año
2050 piezas de oro las 1000 con las que
iniciamos y las 50 que estamos re
invirtiendo en el capital
quizá compramos nuevos equipos o más
tierra etcétera imaginemos también que
en el año 2 creció el ingreso nacional
recordamos que estamos en una economía
super simplificada que es solamente una
mina de oro y ahora el ingreso nacional
creció un 2 por ciento
ahora es de 102 piezas de oro hay muchas
maneras de repartir esto pero para
nuestro ejemplo se es igual a 2 %
la cuestión es y esto es una de las
cuestiones centrales del libro debido a
que r es más grande que se en esta
situación va a ocasionar que una parte
más grande del ingreso nacional vaya a
los dueños del capital o va a ocasionar
lo contrario o el nivel de desigualdad
se mantendrá neutral los invito a que
pause del vídeo y reflexionen sobre esto
por su cuenta
dados todos estos números encuentren
diferentes maneras de repartir el
ingreso nacional del año 2 cuánto podría
ir a la mano de obra y cuánto podría ir
al capital y en esta situación en que
eres mayor que se siempre nos va a
generar mayor desigualdad bueno esto
depende de cómo divida el ingreso sin
duda podemos tener una situación en la
que tengamos un crecimiento potencial de
la desigualdad por ejemplo que la mano
de obra reciba las mismas 50 piezas de
oro
mientras que el capital reciba 52 piezas
de oro
ahora el rendimiento en el capital será
entre 1.050 usamos la calculadora para
ver cuánto es esto
52 entre 1050 la cantidad del ingreso al
capital es 52 y el valor del capital es
1050 piezas de oro por lo que nuestro
rendimiento del capital es de 4 puntos
95 por ciento casi 5% así que en este
escenario el rendimiento del capital r
es aproximadamente igual a 4.95 por
ciento de nuevo vemos que r es mayor que
se aquí los dueños del capital tendrán
una mayor parte del ingreso más del 50%
así que aumentó un poco a la desigualdad
pero también podemos tener lo contrario
vamos a quitar esto quizá la mano de
obra recibe un aumento de sueldo este
año por lo que 52 piezas de oro van a la
mano de obra y 50 piezas de oro van al
capital cuál será el rendimiento de
capital aquí pues va a ser 50
esencialmente es el mismo ingreso pero
entre una inversión más grande
1050 que es y aquí usamos la calculadora
50 entre 1050 nos va a dar 4 puntos 76
por ciento aproximadamente esto es
aproximadamente igual a 4.76 por ciento
como pueden ver en este análisis
tremendamente simplificado podemos ver
que comparando superficialmente reconoce
de un año al siguiente no significa
necesariamente que se vaya a tener un
aumento en la desigualdad del ingreso
este ejemplo puede ser una manera de
alto nivel de ver las cosas pero
asimismo si alguien les dice que en un
año el rendimiento del capital es mayor
que el crecimiento económico no se puede
asegurar que en ese año se tenga un
aumento en la desigualdad lo que haremos
en los próximos vídeos es ver con más
detalle esta cuestión y usar hojas de
cálculo para analizar algunos escenarios
en donde por ejemplo mantengamos el
constante
r hice constantes y ver qué sucede con
la desigualdad o quizás mantengamos
constante la desigualdad y ver cómo se
comporta efe pero esto lo veremos en el
siguiente vídeo